[Musique]
le chien personnes
alors qu'est ce que c'est mais qu'est ce
qu'on entend la voix mais robben j'ai
regardé
qui est là c'est une surprise qui tue je
m'appelle ulysse je suis le marchand de
sable et ils amis de tous les enfants du
monde et tous les petits enfants et
petits-enfants noah oui des petits
enfants noirs des petits chinois comme
des petits indiens
chaque soir je survole la terre entière
pour voir si tous les petits enfants vos
sagement se coucher et en même temps
je sais mon sable
qu'est-ce qu'il fait ensemble lui il
donne envie aux petits enfants d'aller
se coucher comme ça et vous mes deux
petits amis comment vous appelez-vous
jeu mental
oui et moi me ramène petit louis et
mirabel quel âge avez vous vingt cinq
ans mois quatre ans est ce que vous êtes
bien sage
ah oui et bien si vous êtes toujours
je viendrai vous voir chaque soir moi
aussi mais y'a pas peur les enfants lui
ces gros ours mon fidèle compagnon
il m'accompagne dans tous mes voyages je
suis le vieux copain de tous les enfants
qui me connaissent bien
oui je suis gros mais je suis aussi très
gentil c'est moi qui en mai dolly les
garnements qui ne veulent pas y aller où
il se fait tard allons au dodo et hop
voilà mon propos pour d'autres c'est le
local une hausse qui viendra nous voir
tous les squares et qui nous racontera
des histoires bon quand vous aurez des
biens s'en aller
[Musique]
pourquoi gauche au revoir au revoir
voilà une bonne chose de faite
[Musique]
ça y est le fait vous voyez
petit louis et mirabel sont maintenant
couchez vous tous aussi à aller vite au
lit et si vous êtes très sage nous
reviendrons vous voir demain soir bonne
nuit des enfants rois
[Musique]
on